so you might know this by now former
president obama said to have scaled back
the guest list for his 60th birthday
bash but man was that tent big dana
uh the party did go on hundreds of
guests in attendance the former
president can be seen in pictures
hitting the dance floor
without a mask we're told that he danced
all night and had a great time happy
birthday to the president
joe conscious immediate politics
columnist for the hill and a fox news
contributor hello joe to you
here is the coverage by network are you
ready
msnbc two minutes 45 seconds cnn five
minutes fox news channel
17 minutes 35 seconds you want to make
sense of this
oh well it seems that this is being
ignored for some reason wonder why that
is i think that tent by the way is going
to host the super bowl in 2025 you're
right
that thing is big no question about it
but as for our immediate look
no mention of obamafest anywhere on the
sunday talk shows either and instead i'm
watching chuck todd who will never be
confused with tim russert
on meet the press and he broached
instead the sturgis biker rally
in an interview with ubiquitous dr fauci
and fauci went off on the biker rally
but didn't bring up the former
president's
massless mega party so it may lead to an
increasing number of people starting to
think that the doctor
is seeing things through a political
prism than a scientific one either way
our so-called leaders are not leading by
example bill dana whether that's the
former president obama
whether that's newsom pelosi lightfoot
bowser
countless others all caught breaking
their own rules but they don't care
because they know that most of the media
they're going to provide cover instead
of actual you know
coverage okay so a couple of things here
uh labor day weekend a year ago
the president former president tweeted
it might be labor day weekend but let's
all remember that we're still in the
middle of a pandemic
wear a mask practice social distancing
and follow the experts
it'll save lives well that was before we
had the vaccine so a lot
a lot of things have changed since then
but there was this segment with the new
york times reporter on cnn
who said the following about those who
attended going to be safe this is a
sophisticated vaccinated crowd
and and this is just about optics it's
not about safety
this is a sophisticated vaccinated crowd
and it's
just about optics glenn greenwald yeah a
new york times reporter on cnn
justifying obama's huge massless
birthday bash
because he only got number four guys he
only invited a sophisticated vaccinated
crowd
is about as emblematic of liberal
discourse as it gets
what happened all the concerns about
vaccinated people passing delta to the
unvaccinated so what do you think about
the
sophisticated crowd in martha's vineyard
joe
well let's be clear the new york times
reporter there her name is annie carney
she said she was simply sharing the
sentiment of one
martha's vineyard resident from the
story who said the whole thing was
overblown but i think in that case on
national television
maybe i would have spoken to some
doctors on the island instead or the cdc
to get a clearer picture
instead by presenting this argument that
the guest list is a sophisticated crowd
seems to imply that the smart and
responsible were going to be smart and
responsible enough to take the necessary
risks or steps to avoid contracting the
virus but if you look at those photos
the smart and the sophisticated
completely flaunted any concept of
masking
social distancing indoors by the way
just because the tent was outside bill
it doesn't make it an outdoor event this
was an indoor event and the cdc
it deems dukes county that's where
martha's vineyard is located that is a
high
transmission area and therefore requires
mass but the president and obama and
seemingly most of his guests
ignored that while dancing inside and by
the way if that party was so safe
if the criticism's so overblown then why
did the dj at the party who put the
photos up on social media why was he
ordered to delete them because it may
look like they're hiding something
rules for thee not for deeds
you know we were told all last week that
they're scaling this thing back i said
to dana during a commercial right what
did they scale back
and i i guess she said that nancy pelosi
didn't go
or and you could harry david and david
axelrod i think i think larry david
actually might have placed him on the
island there anyway that's
i mean um get your super bowl tickets
for martha's vineyard
thank you joe yeah nice to see you let's
talk to you later
thank you